vanessa bryant surprises her daughters
and her late husband kobe bryant's
family with a trip
to jamaica the 39 year old widow of the
late nba star took to instagram this
week to share pics from her tropical
vacation with her kids
and extended family in one snap vanessa
and her daughters
18 year old natalia four-year-old bianca
and two-year-old capri
pose with kobe's sister and
brother-in-law sharia and jared
washington
along with their kids taya sydney and
jett
the caption family vanessa went on to
share a second group shot from their
vacation which she captioned with red
heart emojis
but her family getaway kicked off with
this snap of capri
looking cool in some oversized shades on
the plane
heading to their destination once the
fam touched down
they spent time at the pool and the
proud mama posted
these pics of her youngest tots check
out this video of vanessa taking a dip
with coco
now this is what relaxation looks like
the crew also went tubing golfing
and enjoyed meals with a view sharia
shared pics from her time in jamaica too
and praised her sister-in-law for
planning the surprise vacay
she wrote i'm not sure how she does it
but vanessa bryant pulled off
another huge surprise family trip to
jamaica
absolutely amazing
summer certainly looks good on the
bryant family they've been busy living
life to the fullest at events like the
fast nine premiere
earlier this month here's natalya and
vanessa
turning heads on the red carpet in neon
ensembles
the mother-daughter pair posed for
photos with the movie stars vin diesel
and tyrese but the exciting moments
hardly end there
natalia also graduated high school and
committed to attend college at usc
i got it
she also looked like a pretty pink
princess at her senior prom
a milestone event that she went to while
her mom held down the fort
at kobe bryant's posthumous induction
into the basketball hall of fame
ceremony
i'm sure he's laughing in heaven because
i'm about to praise him in public
for his accomplishments on one of the
most public stages
i can see him now arms folded with a
huge grin
saying isn't this some sh
and while kobe may be gone his memory
and legacy continue to live on
both vanessa and natalya shared touching
tributes to the late basketball icon on
father's day
praising him for being the best girl dad